18 years old he uh he is one of the
highest rated 18 year olds in history
but Magnus Carlsen he is the highest
rated 18 year old in history so he has
that on his side and here we go the game
has started wow so it was an English
opening when these two met in the world
rapid last year this time it's a modern
opening from Magnus and he's done this
before he gets many youngsters it's the
anti-use variation oh well I'm going to
call it that from the Eric icy final
exactly and here we go again are we
gonna see this exactly the same approach
yeah it looks like Abdul satoroff has
suddenly done his homework Magnus has
now played this against Eric I see he's
played against Prague and he's now
played it against Abdus tour of it's no
coincidence they're routines and uh the
problem is just like we were talking
about earlier if you keep repeating the
same opening whether it's a great one or
whether it's a risky one like this
you'll get found out eventually he lost
against eriggaisi yesterday what do you
think Lauren's good I'm I'm actually
very surprised by Magnus playing this
because this this has no longer got any
surprise value uh Abdul satorov prior to
today with his coaches should have
looked at this and various systems
and
I don't really get why Magnus is playing
it because he's actually in a bit of a
danger zone as Ivanka said he's not
going to be too worried but you lose
this game to abdisator of a few wins
below you and suddenly you're like hmm
okay I actually have to start fighting
um don't get it I I I I think you give
you know a player like Abdul saturov who
does so well with the initiative
uh yeah I I just dislike the choice but
I do know that Magnus has got certain
ideas going into games uh certain ways
he wants to play so
but I certainly if I was his manager
wouldn't have advised it or his coach
what do you think I I agree if you're
going to repeat the same opening against
all these really well prepared
youngsters who are clearly doing their
homework with coaches then repeating a
solid one yeah they don't necessarily
repeat something so provocative like
this where you give white the center you
give white the development and okay it
worked out fine for Magnus in the past
but yesterday maybe would have scarred
him and he doesn't look too comfortable
Magnus already thinking at an early
stage after White's very natural moves
what's Castle queenside which means he
is hoping black will maybe Castle the
other way so he can start attacking
yeah Magnus it feels like he's
freestyling in a way and you can't I
mean I would not feel comfortable uh
freestyling against these youngsters
maybe he'll get away with it because
he's so good but and uh there he goes
again pushing the pawn attacking the
Knight but In fairness to Magnus okay
yes he's using the same opening but he
is varying it's not like he's going down
the exact same moves again I mean it's a
very thematic you know he's attacking on
the left side of the board but the exact
move order is going to be do is
different
yeah those are very similar move very
similar though it is very similar there
you know Eric guys he jumped into the
middle and now that's not possible Right
so I mean there I just don't want to be
too harsh that's what let's be harsh
that's really hard because we hold
magnets to high standards which he does
for himself and
I don't think I would recommend this to
a student I would not recommend doing
the same opening especially if you've
had some mixed experiences and
especially if your opponent is someone
like this Abdus who I've seen some of
his games the homework level is just
incredible
um but yeah you're right Ivanka he's
trying to mix it up at least Magnuson
maybe it's an advert for being loyal to
your openings if he turns around and
wins this one Magnus then we'll be
praising him but yeah
so okay abduce the tour of thinking
where is he gonna put this Knight that's
attacked by Black's Pawn I just liked
his body language there did you see it
you know it looked like he was scanning
the board although it's not bored it's a
screen and uh where he's gonna put the
Knight I agree with you maybe he's gonna
do you think he's gonna step it all the
way back to the starting Square I've
seen that idea I've also seen the Knight
just uh go and park itself in front of
the light squared Bishop
a few choices and just before we jump
into the game to analyze variations I
want to say that there's a game going on
from the previous round still it's now
move 118 uh and it's bishop and Knight
versus King wow and uh Rapport is going
to win that one but Rapport and metal
they're still battling it out
they've been going for over an hour now
in their previous game so uh yeah hats
off to those guys for fighting and
actually that's a critical game because
Rapport was on 13 points so if he wins
that
he's there's a real bunch of players
around the fifth to eighth position so
this is uh this is actually getting
quite dangerous if Magnus if so if he
has an accident here he could actually
be out the top eight by the end of this
round and oh still having to start
having to really work to to make it into
the finals you know I had an interesting
fact about the night and Bishop mate
yeah
um and it actually involves you Lawrence
yeah I think it was a bishop and light
mate uh it was during a podcast with
Fabiana carwan he said there's only one
person in the world who I know who can
perform that mate in 10 seconds yeah I
did a challenge a few years ago where I
could mate anywhere on the board in 15
seconds or something like that yeah um I
remember doing it with you and Fabiano
in 2015 once and yeah you did it in
around 15 seconds yeah that's what
happens when your teachers
you could you could you could do the
maid obviously it's a very important
Checkmate and I would recommend anybody
actually learn that Checkmate it's it's
not a Checkmate you don't want to know
how to deliver in a tournament game can
be very embarrassing it's one of the the
standard checkmates along two Bishops
along with obviously King and rook and
king and queen do learn United Bishop
it's a bit more complex but there is a
nice method so and the game has now
finished yes it went for Richard let's
take a look at the current standings
with all games finished in round 10. so
uh yeah Richard report is now only one
point behind Magnus Carlsen same score
as Anish giri and gukash is also right
inside top eight in that crucial eighth
place with the Vincent kymer three
points behind
trying to get inside top eight all right
he is not entirely safe Magnus calls and
he will need points in this game yeah so
he can't quite drop out the top eight
yet after this round but he could
seriously have to start watching his
shoulder looking over his shoulder if he
loses again and with black against Abdus
it's not an easy pairing and let's go
back to this game because there have
been some small developments it is
different from the battle against Eric I
see yesterday as Ivanka pointed out
Magnus used a different move order in
the opening as black and after a trade
of knights white has a set of doubled
Pawns in the center on the D file what
do we think about those it's very risky
actually what episode has done I I have
no idea why he played Knight E5 in that
position that looks like a really
uh just uh unnecessary decision Knight
C2 was natural Knight A4 I didn't like
so much but why why why allow this trade
because you're right he could have gone
to a bunch of squares so he could have
gone to any of these four he chose this
one and uh after Knight takes uh Knight
Magnus attacked this pawn and I was kind
of half expecting abdusator to just grab
this guy and say okay you can take my
Central Pawn but maybe if I bring my
Bishop out or for example then I'm still
relatively healthy I'm not sure who's
who's happier here of the two but Abdul
satorov surprises me surprises Magnus
perhaps by just not touching the spawn
ignoring these guys instead of bringing
his Knight out first
um makes some sense I guess if Bishop
takes porn now he's just going to attack
this bishop with his knight uh ask this
bishop where to go and if it goes back
now he will take this Pawn with his
Queen
this looks like White's gaining a whole
bunch of time so uh what is Magnus gonna
do in the current position so this is
White's idea to defend the Central Pawn
I mean yeah is it such a big deal to
allow the Knight to that square can you
not I mean knowing Magnus I was just
thinking he's just going to develop a
piece
and just get on with harmonies
harmonizing the his forces yep yep you
can go after this Pawn uh with the Black
Knight it's not going to survive long
this Pawn right whoa
probably not but actually after Queen
takes B4 now yeah hitting the bishop
Bishop takes porn for example and now
let's say Knight F4 yeah you're gonna
throw in Rook B8 I assume yep and now if
I go for example Queen A3 which looks or
maybe Queen A4 is actually interesting
now I put
the pin yeah
if I drop back Bishop back I'm not sure
where yeah and uh yeah it's still very
interesting white can grab a pawn but
there are some open lines towards the
white king and this didn't happen in the
drive yeah instead he just defended this
form that we've been talking about
but now you give white all these
opportunities to give a check and then
plant the bishop on C6 in some positions
check or 97 Knight F4 and you've got all
kinds of
or even Bishop H6 here actually Bishop
H6 looks very interesting here you're an
aggressive mood Lawrence yeah it's time
to time to play aggressive yeah yeah but
still you know White's King is also not
that safe so can you looks pretty safe
pieces around it
yeah for the time being I don't like
this with black at all because after
let's say you Castle here okay can we
start to be really cavemen like Queen
Chief oh well we're going to see it
because well we're going to see it he's
played it and I was wondering okay
black has an option he can capture the
bishop he can move the king to protect
the bishop by castling and also just uh
what about kind of stepping one square
as well yeah run away from this exchange
but now the black King's cutting uh it's
cut off from castling yeah this is the
move actually I wanted wow okay
interesting stuff from Magnus uh just
shuffles his King
defend his Bishop oh no the bar hates it
no I mean this is just
this is one thing we show kids and it's
like who don't do this even if Magnus
turns it around again and wins it again
is
he's definitely not trying to set an
example for the young ones
um for getting to Castle here
the whole idea I guess Ivanka is that if
the bishops get traded off now blacks
rook's actually just as good in the
corner as it would be on this square if
it had castled
and also with the King on this Square
yeah I mean at least it can run away
back to the center if it really needs to
if it gets attacked it can run either
side yeah and uh I I think the main
point is just really that uh it becomes
very difficult for white to kind of find
a clear plan of attack whereas before if
you just Castle then it becomes like
yeah yeah just trade off Bishops move
the Knight push the hey H Pawn La La La
follow the formula yeah
yeah so so whilst uh magnus's move is
quite unconventional
I mean still Abdul sotorov has to come
up with a plan and that's not going to
be as easy so we see Bishop takes Bishop
Kane has to capture he defends this Pawn
which was attacked uh in the center
defends it and Magnus loses night out
he's coming for the spawn
he is coming but here you go here comes
Harry
what's coming for the king yeah
and uh yeah now it is no one's getting
really shaky for Magnus the fact that
the evaluation bar is on white side
does tell me that this attack is
probably uh is pretty scary
how do you even defend against this kind
of caveman idea of pushing the pawn
forward do do you block this Pawn
yourself Magnus says no it would have
been one idea maybe to push the pawn
forward and block the advance but he's
happy to go for this Pawn
and if white continues with the attack
this Pawn is gone right you can't defend
it if white continues with the attack
I think you have to play H5 here
basically do we take this Pawn do we
guess what else do you want to do I
don't know just is is is is is uh Abdul
satoru's idea actually to play H6 check
maybe after let's say 965 H6 and just
claim that The Rook on on h8 is going to
be locked out and now just played Bishop
C4 for example it just looks just just
just play chess and claim that uh The
Rook is yeah well he's going for it
we're probably going to see it this is
the alpha zero approach right to push
this Pawn forward uh for example in that
position you mentioned Lawrence
um when I was young when people would
play this like Simon Williams would do
this against me the idea was always to
take this pawn and open up the H file
but modern players uh they push it
forward to H6
just to essentially
offer piece and to create checkmating
threats long term and we'll find out the
answer to your question I think he will
do it it's very very natural to do this
maybe you could start with attacking the
Knight and then flick this one depending
on what black does but either way I
think you're right that must be the idea
maybe you flick this one in first okay
he's played your move
very sensible
well the King has to go back
um I'm sorry I'm just looking at this
tweet from Aaron here so I noticed a
pattern an interesting correlation
between uh Magnus and his losses and his
hair oh wow oh wow the longer the hair
okay the more Magnus blunders
yeah interesting I have not noticed that
I've got to say no I haven't noticed
that either it's the inverse for me
I've blundered more than ever nowadays
I've got none of it
maybe a week then yeah if I start
wearing a wig I might put on some rating
points yeah you're still winning every
game but you know your chest boxing a
payment are Mom yeah Hamilton did that
actually you know he quite famously yes
refused to shave and he did he became a
grand master and I remember seeing him
tournaments of it it was just getting
bushier and bushier
story of uh how uh he was photographed
standing behind Magnus I think it was in
the Isle of Man and then there were
headlines all over it was like Magnus
attacked by uh hobo yeah it was just her
man just with a big bid
but uh okay meanwhile
um your move on the board and the bishop
comes out I mean all of these moves just
flow really
um I'm not convinced it's that great I
mean the bar says zero but in a in a
practical game you tend to feel like
you would take white here right but you
don't have much to
it's never gonna say even after let's
say let's just say but standard
continuation Knight takes F4 Queen 604
D5 okay
even there you don't have that much to
Chomp on Queen D6 then follows and
whoops sorry attacking this Pawn Yeah
Blackwood block and you're right
actually the bishop drops back and you
can just offer a trade of Queens but
Knight B6 is incredibly
hold on a second
it feels weird right it feels so weird
this move it feels like you're pushing a
piece away from your king
and I mean there are already flashy
ideas such as just putting your Bishop
on the Square and just saying okay I'm
leaving it there for a long time uh if
you ever take me then the Knight will
jump in with the deadly check
I'm not sure this is what Abdul satoraf
will do or will want to do maybe he just
Retreats the bishop
and what is Black's plan then well I
mean the I think it's quite I didn't I
quite good move actually from Magnus
um because the bishop is being chased
away from a very powerful diagonal
and now you know
abdusatorov just moves it forward
makes sense
yeah and he's getting ready to do what
Magnus does best you know develop his
Queen connect his Rooks come forward
outclass everyone yes porn up as well so
if he can defend if he can put his Queen
on a nice post then it's unclear where
White's attack comes from
what about the move Rook D to E1 here
okay uh White can slide across you're
lining up a sacrifice for right lining
up maybe even Rook takes E6 because
rookie 8 check exists at the end there
nice and if you Rook takes Pawn just to
show this with a fork yeah and if uh if
Queen F6 was that what the movie yeah I
was gonna suggest this move and now can
we go G4 okay you want to destabilize my
queen
yeah it looks tempting maybe we'll see
something similar in the game he brought
his other Rook to the square yeah I
didn't like that run because I felt like
The Rook did a good job just holding
that pawn but okay he's playing much
more
sort of
sophisticated sophisticated yeah that's
the correct word yeah not necessarily
good just sophisticated yeah I mean it's
not on the Square yeah
but I'm not sure it has any
follow-through after the night gets to
that uh Square this looks like a
hippopotamus defense again uh from
Magnus just kind of these pawns on the
third rank uh just sitting very solid
Magnus you can just put his Bishop on
this Square on D5 and
no threats right uh and I don't see
anything at all for white here do we
think we'll see Magnus maybe do a dance
with his King try and bring it around
this way for sure uh maybe later on okay
he actually starts with that now wow
okay he moves his King out of the way
maybe the idea is just to get his Rook
out at some point uh later on
but the king relatively safe yes it's
stared down by the white Rook but
I don't see any way to get to this uh to
this King yet looks quite well fortified
okay the Knight comes in but as you guys
said no threats wait wait one second did
Magnus really put his King
on the screen on that square
why not run away like the Teletubbies
the square and then you're hiding behind
your Bushman Knight okay
I wasn't expecting that that's all makes
some sense uh the King was in the way of
the black rook in the corner and now the
black rook in the corner can come out
later
all right we are 22 moves into this game
Richard reports who played that super
long game in around 10. it's finished
with a super quick draw in this one
against the niche giri they only played
16 moves 14 moves I think they played
the famous Berlin draw
hundreds of times in chess lately
report maybe a little bit tired after
that long Marathon game and both of them
inside top eight feeling that draw is a
good result
yeah probably because giri has black so
as black you can't really do much
sometimes about these types of opening
drawers with report yeah I guess he's in
a decent position he wants to recover
from that Marathon game yeah we can
forgive the players in situations like
that yeah because we hardly see quick
draws this season exactly yeah
yeah this is the first time we've seen
it in this tournament has anyone else
taken that uh I remember a few actually
um yeah maybe three or four but
barely any yeah yeah I mean it was a
pandemic and it was in uh 2021 when
everyone was doing it but now
the youngsters they forced everyone to
fight we love it a lot of Fighting Chess
and the other game still going on
this is round 11 out of 15. Magnus he is
fighting to get back on the wedding
track
after losing to gukesh in the first
round today a draw against Hare Krishna
in the second and here he is again 18
year old Abdu satorab
yeah parking his Bishop in the center
this bishop can't be kicked away I like
it
um what do you guys think the evaluation
Bar says 0.0 clearly it's very
imbalanced still who would you pick
ing me my extra porn yeah I don't care
no because I mean the thing is that I
can see the progress for for black you
know he just has to kick some of the
White's pieces the way I'm thinking of
that light squared Bishop
and then find a safe haven for the king
and then just live happily ever after
and I like the vagueness of this I hope
this conclusion you know it's not going
to the fine details I mean we can count
the pawns we see blacks one Pawn up the
computer says plus one makes sense right
it's uh yeah for a human point of view
you're right Ivanka you just go step by
step that's uh I think what Magnus will
try to do
okay first he kicks back the white
Bishop you mention this yeah official
oil retreat
somewhere
yeah somewhere and then the Black Knight
might rearrange itself the black king
can just get off the back rank finally
so what do you think right now what will
be the result in this game Magnus win
okay
I think uh there's a really good chance
Magnus does win uh I haven't loved the
way
Abdus that sort of has played the past
sort of six seven moves
that said it's still very complicated uh
but Magnus I think understands that this
is a really big game to win now for the
for the tournament standings
but a lot can happen you go King B1 here
you play Rook C1 you play C4 if you can
um
The Wider still got levers yeah and you
can see the bar is slapped that slap in
the middle are
hmm
yeah white has some plans like you said
I mean firstly this is a nice Outpost at
some point for the night to occupy this
this lever you mentioned Lawrence uh
maybe he'll play it next
he's cleared the square for his Rook
okay Black's Rook coming into the game
now I'm slightly surprised by that one
because I thought the White Knight could
go and attack this Pawn which is now
undefended the Black Brook was
previously holding on to that one
but uh another option like you said just
move the Rook across and start pushing
pawns forward
whose King is going to be more open if
the uh if lines
the report exchanges for example if
loans do open up unclear
just completely unclear this position
yeah totally and uh you know with that
Rook move Magnus is perhaps uh planning
to push his a pawn up the board as well
and uh well
you should be a fortune teller David
Lawrence's idea yeah yeah I mean this is
again how different our brains are
Lawrence I wanted to play King B1
because I was scared black would take my
Pawn if I didn't defend it uh you want
to play King B1 because you can free up
a square for your Rook to attack
and uh that's very stylistic thing Abdus
tour of is in the Lawrence tread School
of Chess clearly and he's trying to open
up lines now
against the king
I wish he was in my school of Chess I
mean I wish I had a 100th of his talent
I mean he's honestly I've spoken to uh a
lot of a lot of GM's top Grandmasters
about about this young man and the
reviews are just
very very very uh
um
what's the word or they're just awesome
I mean they're five star review
everybody's saying the talent the the
raw talent that Abdul satorov has has
not been seen since you know the likes
of Magnus himself wow that's
he's a very very special very very
special player and now he's as we saw in
the interview yesterday he's fully 100
uh focused on chess so I assume that
means he's given up school which is
obviously always a big move but with
with the the future the potential he has
I don't blame him also with the support
of his country I mean when he won the
well rapid you know the government
rewarded him when they won the Olympiad
I think they all got a house each you
know they all got gifted a house or a
car at least or something like that
right and then he got a house for the
being World rapid you know a flat worth
50 times the annual salary uh of
Uzbekistan when he uh won the world
rapper Championship he's a superstar in
his country so you have to pursue it you
have no choice so
um but yeah I mean even in this position
we have here this is a three result game
I don't even know who I would take here
yeah me neither to be honest uh I'm a
materialist so I would say black but I
would also be terrified of any incoming
attack against the black king
white pawns are all really really far
Advanced yeah so you have to be careful
here if things open up
even an end game isn't going to be
completely safe for black if lines open
up for the white Bishop the white Rooks
okay
we're far from the end game Magnus I
mean he's never going to be able to
exchange Queens yes he's opponent but
the rest of his position is a bit smelly
he does have three minutes more on the
clock Magnus yeah he does but his big
priority at the minute is first of all
anticipating everything that and now
Abdus is threatening and then he will be
also calculating how to keep his King
safe and so he said well there's no
threat so far so I'm just going to push
forward with his pawns and uh well Abdus
tariff will also be thinking of the same
kind of way he'll be also thinking what
is Magnus planning okay there's no
threat then he will continue with his
own plan and that will be to Target The
King and I have to say it's not natural
what the the hitting point is
and he steps forward with the F Pawn
presumably the idea is to lift that pawn
once Square further and Magnus on the
meantime gets the first punch in
and uh
well abdusator of swiftly close the
closes the position down
it's just such a weird Pawn structure I
mean you nearly never see this white has
kind of got that thorn in Black side the
white H6 Pawn that's really a nuisance
in the end game middle game Black's got
the same on A3
It's relatively blocked apart from the
uh the fact that black is a pawn up and
where do you put the Black Knight no
idea which Bishop looks really good
could we see a situation where neither
side really does much well I think the
problem with magnus's position is that
finding I mean he is the guy you want
playing Black here because you find your
swimmers but hasn't white got a just a
very clear idea of playing D5 at the
right moment I mean D5 looks
looks like the break you want to make
because if the C file opens obviously
there's a discovered check the file
opens the queen is very vulnerable
what are you supposed to do against D5
uh
but if but if you kind of look at the
consequences of d F because every move
has a consequences you give up the C5
Square for the Knight you open the long
diagonal for say for instance the queen
doesn't have too many squares but oh
David's putting it she knows I want to
put it in the corner but that's not
really threatening mate ever right I can
always throw the Rook on C2 and that's
that's that's very true but it's
something that white always has to keep
an eye on so
yeah those
it comes with a no some benefit some
pros and cons I actually think why if
white doesn't play D5 he's running very
little risk though he could just Shuffle
you know uh how does black actually
intend to make progress here
you could even hint later that you'll
play this movie yeah I was gonna say
like imagine you played a move like
rugby six here I I assume C5 would be
very strong there yeah yeah just ripping
open uh one line towards the black king
I think that's why you want to push this
Pawn right Lawrence because then you can
guarantee at least one line will be open
uh because yeah threaten two pawns at
once and the same if you could play this
move without allowing black to block it
up and it's going to be very very strong
and magnuses I mean his Rooks are stuck
right so this Rook is stuck defending
this Pawn uh this Rook can't kind of go
anywhere decent maybe you kind of put it
on this square or maybe the square and
just sit and wait but uh those Rooks are
stuck the King does it really want to
kind of start dancing back this way
later maybe but it's at the moment it's
tied down to the defense of this Pawn
Black's Queen maybe could be improved as
we just pointed out okay he does move
his Rook
so maybe aimed against one of your Pawn
precious Lawrence uh one of these two
but the black Rook again looks a bit
clumsy here and white doesn't need to
commit white could also just wait for
example with his Bishop just say what
are you doing next
I mean it is tempting however to what
happens if you do a push I'm just
curious yeah I'm
hoping you wouldn't ask how to replace
it we can let Magnus answer answer this
one I thought maybe he could just leave
that pawn there
okay and do you bypass it do you no I um
I thought you could even just leave
everything as is because the real idea
is that yeah just put the night
let's see five yeah yeah and if the
bishop moves
eventually you're gonna have to commit
something because this is a threat
if you have a Trader set of pawns for
example suddenly I don't like the idea
of this line opening that's why that's
why I'm advocating
hold firm keep calm and carry on you
know just make any other move like move
the queen move the queen out of the way
I don't know okay yes you can be worried
that things will open up but maybe it's
okay maybe it's black is solid enough
with the blockade on the dark squares
for now yeah that's yeah let's just see
what Magnus does because there's so many
options in the current game position he
could swap a set of Pawns he could lock
it up immediately he can move his Queen
like you say ivanko move his Knight
hmm it's yeah I mean it's just
inspiration well just uh seeing these
youngsters just show no fear like this
tweet says
um I mean it's not that Magnus is losing
his grip it's far from it it's just the
fact that the youngsters are coming up
and doing so well
um we have to say that you know we've
seen an incredible generation of talent
I mean it's we haven't seen the likes
before where we have people like
pragnanda erici
um
or challenging the players at the top
and even now in the U.S championships we
saw Christopher you 15 years old you
know he defeated levonaronian and he
already
oh yeah yeah didn't he yeah I think you
drew he drew defeated Wesley so defeated
Wesley so yes but yeah I mean maybe not
since magnus's generation when I mean
there was a bunch of uh kind of top 10
players but that's how it worked right
there's a generation eventually a new
generation will come and take over the
uh their place
and you often need competition like we
see at the moment and uh meanwhile okay
a set of porn trades and Magnus is
blocked with his Rook
things are opening there yeah I guess
here you take on E6 out of principle
because you wanna uh it's it's it's not
a mandatory move but it's the first move
I would look at here
I think black is committed to taking
back with the porn that Queen takes
looks fishy to me yeah so you want to
take this Pawn Lawrence to open the
bishop up even further Queen takes these
things oh hang on a second look at that
move that's appeared on the board he's
just just throwing his forward and black
can capture that pawn twice but I I
don't like it at all I hate it if I go
E5 here sorry what's going on yep
easy move block it up yeah what's this
bishop doing now
I mean Magnus plays it immediately
I mean this is where sometimes the
youngsters again they just they want to
play the flashy moves right they want to
be super aggressive but sometimes you
just take a time out just trade a set of
Pawns maybe move your Bishop away
somewhere I'm not sure where uh didn't
mean that square I meant this one and
eventually you try and line up your
queen on this diagonal for example with
the bishop looks really scary I really I
would be terrified here with black uh
with this King but suddenly
the game situation just like you said
Lawrence after white pushed forward
really flashy move the whole idea is if
one takes the bishop takes and the queen
is attacked discovered attack but uh
block it up block positions favor
Knights uh Bishops hate block positions
okay the root moves
how can abdisator justify
allowing the position to block up
okay Rook takes Rook Magnus could just
kind of plant his Knight on this Outpost
now
cannot be challenged there
just looks like good night against Bad
Bishop
uh okay once I mean this way of Chess is
just so out of my so modern so out of my
visual it's it's quite I mean
Victor coachnoy would we imagine the the
tirade you would get on on playing F5
allowing E5 yeah if he was still around
I I just I tell you what he would
approve of though he would approve of
that Rook move grab yes grabbing yes and
uh well but you're right I mean the Old
Masters they'll be like this shows no
strategic understanding but youngsters
they don't care they just calculate so
well even if it looks ugly like we think
it does they make it work because
they've calculated they've worked and
they've seen that they have specific
concrete ideas they don't play in
general terms anymore and now they're
talking of concrete ideas there is
probably a threat of Rook takes the
Black Knight
and then the White Queen comes in very
dangerous no probably about it it's
that's a sacrifice you play without
thinking without thinking yes because
you know you have at least a perpetual
and to be honest it's probably just
winning so
what is okay Queen E7 and now okay
Magnus indirectly defends his Knight
what is the word to describe this game
is it tense
it's weird because we're keeping
creative though yeah I've been very
creative
it is a high level game as well
um we've been slightly critical of one
or two moves but
I mean in general has been uh I mean
both players going at each other
throwing everything in and
okay the black queen just came from the
square right so if Abdus goes back with
the White Queen two squares to the D2
Square
that's the second time we've seen that
position
he could at least ask that psychological
question to Magnus do you want to repeat
do you want the draw do you want to play
for more
I think that's what I would do even if
I'm not intending to force a draw he
does go back and he he doesn't have so
much time on the clock you know just
under four minutes so I think it's a
good thing to do it's very practical
gain some time on the clock and force
Magnus to take a decision we've seen
Magnus take tremendous risks against
people he wants to beat I mean he almost
lost against Aditya metal because he was
so determined to win and we've also seen
him other games as well where he refuses
to take the draw and as a result of that
finds himself in trouble yeah
yeah
and this is not the type of position
that you can risk too much because
Black's King is so open
you're right Ivanka he wants to risk he
wants to avoid repeating the position
what else can black do though because uh
that black B Pawn is attacked by the
white Rook
can't defend it might just be one of
those Dynamic equality kind of positions
where actually neither side can truly do
something he's trying Magnus yeah he's
gonna try because that's that's his
nature
um so a bit of a waiting move it looks
like he's just getting ready to maybe
tuck the black king behind this uh
behind this Rook I do Satora for
Retreats his Bishop
makes sense that Bishop was sometimes
vulnerable to the Black Knight
and uh it's also so super important to
think about the consequences here so I
like what Abdul soturf has done just
maintaining the balance I would not be
advocating capturing porns because
you've got to assess the position what
it's going to be like when the court
works are off the board and you'll see
that Black's Queen is just going to be
very powerful
Queen and Knight versus queen of Bishop
it could be that that kind of uh that
duo again
Queen and night we've seen a very strong
but okay Magnus
still in the move he's one minute down
on the clock now abducator looks very
calm with his body language ah very
focused
doesn't look terrified at all which I
would be gotta say uh the king moves so
you can't take on B4 here or or what
well now you can
because there's a check
yeah let's show this
um in the previous position white
retreated his Bishop if he had taken
this Pawn then we would have seen the
Rooks uh get traded and as Ivanka
mentioned the black queen comes out wins
a pawn coming down into the white camp
now but after the bishop retreated
Magnus just put his King
on the same file oh whoops
my Harris uh he puts the same uh the
King on the same file as The Rook so now
there's no time to take the white Rook
is that he pushes and this is the
current position
does white have more than a draw here
does white even have a draw I guess you
can keep giving checks
what about yeah like let's say queen A5
check actually King D7 might be a big
blunder right because the queen trade is
probably very good for white because you
trade you then play F6 check and you
play B4 and check
or or maybe you don't even have to go
before you can go King C1 King D2 and
this looks oh whoops sorry yeah looks
bad okay yep looks very just he just
took the pawn egg ah now he's got Queen
A7 check okay so in the game uh I mean
this is how concrete deals I mean no
check just take a pawn
yeah I guess black has to push what else
oh but if you push
then there's gonna be some tracks on the
board okay there is a check no he's he's
checked on the diagonal here would have
been blocked sorry so uh in this
position
King moves actually checks can be
blocked still for example the check here
will be blocked by the Black Knight
check here maybe the king just moves
again
what do you guys think is this Pawn
strong enough no
but I think it's an enough of a nuisance
to secure a draw
can still be blockaded by White's Queen
and it's uh on its promotion Square
I mean Magnus he's really pushing the
boat out here trying to win again but
risking things again he's now down a
pawn
the world champion
so toroff what is he gonna do I mean I
would probably just flick in a check
just because I have I'm not sure what
else I guess you could go through your
Pawn push as well Lawrence the one you
mentioned yeah but now ah yeah because
Queen E5 does another check around the
back yeah you could start coming around
the back yep
um okay he does go for a check but this
is blocked
and now maybe it's time uh again you
could flick in this pawn move first but
maybe it's time at some point to block
with a White Queen
probably flick in the pawn move right it
was if you if you're going to be greedy
about it then you have to attack Queen
the problem with Queen E2 is Queen takes
G5 actually just exists there right ah
okay Black's attacking that white Jeep
on yep
so oh such a complicated position so
yeah indeed he does attack the queen and
preserve his pawn and now he keeps the
passport on E3 under lock and key it's
very good strategy actually right always
always
guard against the past pawns and uh it's
such a weird position you know the black
queen probably is going to do a well
she's going to do a lot of damage on the
right side but then
is why it's porno that's going to be
racing up the board here they come come
on push Alice two squares okay but
actually this move here does it allow a
draw as well to give a bunch of checks I
don't think black can escape from all
these checks now oh the White Queen can
come back to the a file check the black
king from the front
have you headed towards a draw if Ivanka
you're disappointed yeah because I I
thought that maybe white could uh start
putting Magnus under some pressure but
okay a draw is a good result actually
[Music]
I mean it's decent for both of these in
the standings the draw but I mean both
of them have wanted to win this game
right they've both been taking massive
risks and Magnus looks away he looks
ready to get out of here with a draw
to search for off have more
can he play for the win
can the White Queen go grab some pawns
for example
looks like it's too much maybe
asking too much of the white position
what would you guys do I would just run
out of here with the draw I think with a
minute 25 wow he goes for it oh that's
my boy I like it
wow and because I mean if you want to
you know reach the next level you you've
got to put
the wild Champion under pressure
I mean he is the big boss I mean you
know for sure Magnus will be playing on
against uh him until the very end
and uh what's going to happen next is
you're just going to agree a draw why
are we going to see another Pawn push
we do have uh we do have quite a few
results now in round 11 a big one cash
three points against Mohamed yarov and
beat it he has lost against Eric
Hansen's beat it it's uh outside top
eight now and he really needs to fight
to qualify for The Knockout stage
and this one do you still think it will
be a draw or are they fighting to win
both of them it's been a fighting game
yeah it probably will be a draw
but I I'm really looking forward to see
what happens next because uh he's got uh
Abdus autograph has got on the 50
seconds left and he has to take a
critical decision is he going to go for
the win wow and he just advances his
King he's confident I like it is that a
sign of going for a win bringing your
king into the game
yeah because it's simply just given a
check and just check the king until the
game finishes in a draw instead he's
like no let me play on yeah just to just
to show this on the board of anchor so
for example here it's not necessarily
about the move he played but it's about
the options he could have forced to draw
as you mentioned the queen could come
back with a check the King goes back
another check the king moves another
check for example and the kind of dance
goes on there's no way for the black
king to escape the White Queen but uh
he's going for it look at this advancing
up the board
this reminds me a bit of short versus
Timon 1981 tilburg with the white king
uh in that game the white king kind of
danced up the board and actually helped
to deliver Checkmate hear the white king
started its Journey
it's brave but uh
what to do if the black queen yeah
exactly you might have to bail out
anyway because
or are you gonna play
can you play Bishop C4
B5 keep the game alive now Bishop C4
probably and then you want to kind of
zigzag with you yeah I want to get to B5
with my king okay wow Queen exchange we
weren't looking in that direction we
were looking uh the other way but uh
makes some sense if the Queens come off
now Black's Nike
what is this that's Browning both
players playing for the win but okay
abduce the Toro's last move what's the
threat here what's the queen doing
surely Magnus can start thinking about
either gobbling up a pawn
or he can start pushing some of these
guys
black has a lot of Pawns I mean this
this kind of chest is just
crazy I don't know I don't know I don't
know what what this is I just
came Magnus attacking this bishop now
attacking this Pawn
who would you prefer again I mean it's
it's so hard to say
yeah I would probably take
white still but okay
okay why would that be well I mean
you know black is playing without a
knight on B7 I can take the F7 Pawn in
the right circumstances yeah and Bishop
B5 Queen 65 Bishop C4 uh uh transposes
to the note
uh that this could have happened on the
previous move
okay but uh it's Taco King A3
yeah and I mean you can actually bail
out here right maybe there's a track can
you force a draw here yeah
he has done this
but uh is Magnus gonna be playing for
more
after all there's no threats from White
everybody's such a crazy game uh 45
seconds left for Abdul satoroff and
Magnus just under two minutes anything
can happen wow I love the fact that both
sides are now playing full-on for the
win what a cool game
really really cool game and uh earlier
it was Abdul satoroff who could turn
down the draw now it's Magnus it's up to
him he can take it if he wants just by
checking on C1 and back repeating the
position
what do you think do you think he'll
take it or do you think he'll be like no
you tear me down once
yeah the problem is you've only got the
queen in play and
I don't really see another away at all
to activate and you have some past pawns
right yeah but she pulls up as black
yeah you do run the risk of
I mean there's no immediate threat Queen
takes E3 is a threat yeah okay so you
defend that pawn and then
run your pawns even there like there's a
weird variation for example Queen C1
check King B3 let's say you then go H5
right I can play Bishop D5 potentially
and even when you play Queen D1 check
I've got King C4
and I know it's getting crazy but this
might still be okay for white because
you're just dancing I just protect the
bishop and uncovering some key squares
Queen Z2 I can think about King B5 there
but again this is the king dance we're
talking about you know you can lose
these positions as black for real Agnes
is playing for the win though he doesn't
repeat the position if we go back uh
rather than giving the check on this
Square where he would have forced the
draw he's now gone for a different bunch
of checks and now will we see the King
start marching up the board
if we do and uh Magnus gives another
check now
white does have this very powerful
passport of his own
and okay I'm just a tour of doesn't go
forward I thought maybe he would try go
forward but he's retreated
maybe he's just banking on the fact that
Magnus is not willing to gamble any
further and the Magnus could still give
a check and most likely make a draw
what a game
move 59 I mean I don't think we've
predicted even five of these moves in
the entire game out of those 59 and uh
okay what Magnus do will he give another
check
push this Pawn potentially
lots of ideas in the position
I would be tempted to push the board
Magnus says yes that is close it is one
more square and you have to take this
Pawn off right
uh because if you'd move to the queen to
stop this Pawn then a queen check would
have helped upon promote next move
to the players because uh right now
White's Bishop gave itself up for that
pawn and uh I think we're about to see a
draw because White's Pawn White's F Pawn
is sorry white F1 is just too strong
yeah this will end in a draw but
uh again it's just uh
alien chess to me yeah I just I can't
guess anything actually this movie is
quite tricky I can just playing for the
win still yeah wow so this stops the
white porn advancing because it's pinned
to the White Queen
yeah really ingenious stuff
White Queen has to move surely you have
to go Queen E6 I guess yeah yeah you can
also just uh move the queen
two squares across and just pay no
attention whatsoever
to your King's safety what's King is
safe on its own exactly
just uh get that pawn promoted that will
secure the draw
and uh he steps forward with the queen
no I didn't like this one I didn't like
this one because we have to keep
connection with the Knights oh
my God it's suddenly a win from Magnus
but where is it yeah maybe it's not even
immediate it's just such a weird choice
of square why are you blocking your own
porn I mean if I don't think that's a
threat Magnus just pushes his phone if
the white Pawn advances now the Black
Knight can go over and just capture it
and
what are we okay maybe there's still
some tricks maybe there's still some
tracks
Magnus just missing opportunity if so it
was not obvious
um okay Magnus as well making
kind of gestures that he's not happy
maybe it's still a draw
so moving pushing that pool might not
have been the right move for Magnus
maybe it was just too slow maybe it was
to do with giving some checks with the
black queen instead and uh yeah it looks
like now it should be back to equality
but not an immediate draw the evaluation
bar doesn't say 0.0
and 10 seconds now four minus Carlson
yeah okay give us a track
very sensible
run forward or back no I think you go
backwards here okay I would
oh you want to go play King A4 do you
yeah and okay he does step back this is
safer much safer
yeah it's just the problem is the Black
Knight is dominated by White's b-born
the Black Knight can never jump forward
with any checks
any meaningful jumps
and magnus's pawns are far too slow
compared to White spawn it's just like
you said earlier Ivanka it's the quality
of the pawns not the quantity is it
possible that uh Magnus can sacrifice a
knight to try to keep the game anyway we
see him giving a few track checks this
is good strategy build up time on the
clock before you think about trying to
prolong the game even more
yeah black snake could go and attack
this white Pawn at some point
okay first he gives another check maybe
on the next move
is Magnus gonna try and win Now by
attacking that white Pawn with the Black
Knight giving up the Black Knight for
that F1
it's the only way to try and play for a
win yeah
okay he does give the check first
the king retreating
yeah it's it's hard to it's hard to see
what else he can try Magnus because
white just needs two moves white needs
to move the queen out the way promote
nothing's done
huh
is this one of those traditional Magnus
calls and grinding games that he often
wins
or is it because the Queens are on yeah
because the Queens are on it's just so
concrete it's so it's kind of one move
and you lose or one move by one slip by
your opponent you win also remember that
abdusator of beat Magnus in the world
rapid in a queen end game
um so Magnus may be seeing some ghosts
there
um this is another track it's hard to
know where Magnus wants to end up with
his Queen just even a whole bunch of
checks right now
yeah it's the white king is still doing
that dance still happily moving forward
the next round final round off today
round 12 in the preliminaries will start
in six minutes these two will have 10
minutes after this game to rest and
prepare for the final round of today
but the action continues in only six
minutes and actually David Anton and
mithal they are also still playing but
that game started late because metal
played a very long game in round 10. so
these two they have played now for 75
moves and 55 minutes
and Magnus keeping the game alive you
know he even pre-moved
we're taking that pawn
and uh well now we have a race Queen
again Queen and two points against Queen
and two pawns I don't know I mean
Black's King is pretty unsafe so you
would guess that white always best
option to give some nuisance checks and
the kings are further away from the
black pawns is that an advantage or a
disadvantage because the white king is
close to its two pawns so for black it's
potentially an advantage if the Queens
disappear if they get swapped off then
black is winning because the black King
can stop the white pawns white skin
cannot stop the black bronze the problem
is I don't think you can force a queen
exchange and actually having your king
in front of Pawns is sometimes bad
because the pawns gain time with checks
and uh whites King can kind of hide
behind its own pawns Black's King cannot
hide behind its own Pawns
um actually this end game when black
doesn't have his two pawns it should
still be a draw
um that was a really hard one to to hold
but even if black lost both of his pawns
it should still be fine for him because
he can give a bunch of checks
this one should be a draw with best play
Yeah and I don't think Magnus can risk
it any further
the black kings in serious trouble if
white gets time to check
so yeah give another Track Force that
came back
surely now they've tried long enough
both of them to get that win yeah
you can tell by the facial expression
he's he's done yeah that's the second
time and if he steps the king up and
it's over yeah after 84 moves it ends in
a draw between abdisator of and minus
crossing the world champion shakes his
head he wanted to win this game
desperately but only a draw and one
point a very long game and here is
today's lisavetta learning point